in our school matters series we're
looking at the increased availability of
summer school for students
who fell behind during the pandemic a
recent survey of educators found
97 percent reported a loss of learning
in their students
over the past year compared to earlier
years
and 47 percent said a wider gap between
struggling
and high performing students is the
biggest obstacle to a return to normal
meg oliver is here with us and she spoke
to a mom from new jersey about how she
hopes to get her kids
back on track meg good morning tony good
morning after a year of students staring
at devices
trying to stay connected through remote
learning families are left trying to
figure out what's best between giving
kids a mental health break or
trying to supplement their learning loss
this summer
oh my gosh isn't that crazy rachel wyman
had a problem
after a year of remote learning two of
her kids brought home a bevy of failing
grades
straight ups straight ups as a single
mom and the owner of a bakery in new
jersey
wyman said she had trouble helping her
kids through school
i'm not a high earner so i don't have
resources to pay for
private teachers or pods or private
school
like a lot of people in my community do
so after a frustrating year her
11-year-old son
keegan trudged off to his first day of
summer school on monday
i definitely need it so i don't have
that much of a bad opinion about it but
i prefer not going but i know that i
need to
so he and his 13 year old sister josie
had tried to keep up with virtual school
while working part-time at their mom's
shop are you ready to go on to
eighth grade i don't know i think
like mentally yes but like academically
maybe not and while their mother is glad
they have a summer school option
she doesn't know how effective it will
be is summer school enough
to make up for this learning loss i i
don't know how it could possibly so
they're going
four days a week for three hours a day
for four weeks and that's supposed to
replace an entire school year
students across the country failed
classes at an alarming rate
in the bay area failing grades increased
by 50 percent
in houston about half of high school
students got at least one f
last fall and in new mexico one school
reported that
79 percent of students failed at least
one class
increases in federal funding to schools
have allowed many to offer expanded
summer programs
school offers swimming they offer
cooking
so they besides the school where they're
able to do other things
that are fun muriel watson's kids are
attending summer school at their public
charter school in st
louis nearly 90 percent of missouri's
public charter schools are offering
enriched summer programs how did you
feel about summer school
i actually like summer school because
summer school
basically gives me extra time to like
practice
and get ready for high school you know
the funding that the federal government
has given to states
and that states have been you know doled
out to schools especially to low-income
schools has been really really
significant
alex sieskin runs the 2 and through
project which aims to increase
graduation rates in college enrollment
among under-resourced communities
what should parents be doing who may be
scrambling right now looking at these
report cards with
failing grades with students that
otherwise were doing well before the
pandemic
i think the most important thing is not
to blame students
we need to give them grace you know
offering students
second chances offering students third
chances i think is going to be really
really
important this summer and into the fall
rachel wyman hopes that moving learning
off of screens and
into the classroom will be the second
chance her kids need
when i found out that summer school was
going to be in person instruction and
not remote instruction i got behind it i
think it will be good to provide them
some consistency and you know being able
to interact in an academic environment
again
hoping for the best yeah they love
learning these kids love
learning it's just been taken away from
them
for students in elementary and middle
school siskin says the most important
thing is getting kids
interested in school again through
extracurricular activities
now for high school students one college
admissions officer told me they would
highly recommend summer school
if students failed courses if you have a
rising senior they also suggest
reaching out to their college of choice
now to start a dialogue
on the admissions process i think it's
so important too to get as that teacher
said to sort of basically give kids
a grace period here to kind of come back
and not blame anybody for anything
and a time to because so many people
were affected in so many different ways
in the last year
when i was a kid i would have hated
summer school but this seems like a good
idea under the circumstance you don't
think so don't
i don't know i mean you've been cooped
up in doors in your house and now things
are opening up but you've got to go to
another building and be indoors i think
extra extracurriculars as in outdoor
activities might be the best way to
reacclimate but you know every parent's
going to come to their industry however
we can help them i love josie
in your piece when you asked her about
some respect she goes i don't know
and that's coming from a kid who held
every single class i don't know
she needs a break all right meg thank
you